welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston Hugh Jackman is playing Wolverine
in Deadpool 3 coming September 6 2024
confirmed on social media post by Ryan
Reynolds which honestly is the best way
to Market this movie other than Ryan and
Hugh doing this flirty stick inside of a
giant bottle of Aviation American gin
Deadpool 3 will kick off Marvel Phase 6
with the Fantastic Four Avengers King
Dynasty and secret words to follow but
I'm gonna break down the Easter eggs you
might have missed in these announced
enough as well as a bit of lip reading
of what they were saying under that
music and how this will all fit together
with the continuity from the Deadpool
films the X-Men films Logan and the MCU
so the first announcement video featured
Ryan Reynolds writing on a typewriter
wearing Deadpool's Dusty suit from
Deadpool 2 with the bullet holes in the
duct tape from the ending of that movie
when many of us compared it to the look
of the gray Deadpool suit from the
comics Reynolds pours into a Deadpool
mug some Aviation American gin the Gin
Company that Reynolds co-owns and works
in everything like in the movie free guy
then on the toilet Reynolds reads a
comic book this is Wolverine Volume 7
number 21 published this past May the
most recent team up between Deadpool and
Wolverine and Marvel Comics they fight
danger the sentient form of the X-Men's
danger room here is a specific page that
Reynolds is flipped to showing Deadpool
fighting a swarm of Wolverine
projections sent by danger Reynolds says
he has no ideas but then but we did have
one idea
hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine one
more time
yeah sure right followed by Whitney
Houston's I Will Always Love You the
captions reading it as we'll always love
Hugh with the release date the movies
logo with three Wolverine claw slashes
to mark this as Deadpool three just
perfect and he shared this with the
caption hard keeping my mouth sewn shut
about this one I knocked the 2009 X-Men
Origins Wolverine movie which was the
first time Ryan Reynolds played Wade
Wilson but they infamously fused his
mouth shut now win this posted on
Tuesday unsurprisingly social media blew
up John Krasinski actually shared it
asking if this was our movie in Deadpool
3 director Sean Levy responded sorry JK
this one's all mine director of Logan
and Indiana Jones 5 James mangled
responded with a gift of the moment in
Logan when x24 impales Wolverine on a
tree stump the killing blow and since
everyone was really asking if this would
erase Wolverine's death in Logan mangle
followed up telling everyone to chill
saying Logan will always be their
Multiverse or prequel Time Warp or
Wormhole Cannon or non-ganon or even
without a rationale I cannot wait to see
what Madness my dear friends cook up so
that led to another post from Reynolds
and Jackman seeking to clear it up how
is Wolverine alive yeah after Logan
Logan takes place in 2029 totally
separate thing Logan died in Logan not
touching that what actually happens in
our film is these two so then Ryan
Reynolds and you Jackman riff a bunch of
nonsense covered by whams wake me up but
their words have now been to go to Via
lip reading credit to johnboy Media
Reynolds says these two guys get out
there and Jackman goes yes and Reynolds
says and he's like Jackman says pulls
the thing Reynolds says and I'm just
like and I just catch him Jackman says
and then I but then Reynolds goes on and
I'm chasing him all over the place and
we're going through stuff and through
all these different places Jackman talks
over him saying I'm gonna have this
massive massive huge huge explosion and
Reynolds says yeah and I've got the
swords that [ __ ] boom and Jackman reacts
and whoo and they just make action
noises Jackman Panama's killing Reynolds
who then slumps over and Jackman goes
that's it and he continues to play Punch
Reynolds but he accidentally hits him on
the last one and he breaks saying whoops
and he laughs and round sits back up
saying but I'm fine I'm totally laughing
about it Jackman says and I'm alive too
but you really have to say this because
we're in a prime it's true the prime and
Randall says and what a way to make it
up to you Jackman says I'm so excited
about this you're gonna love it and
Reynolds Ends by saying it's gonna be
the best and he claps signaling everyone
the music part is over leading to thank
you Kevin feige Love You Kevin feige
thank you MCU in advance with the
Polaroids of the two actors together and
then a shot from the set with director
Sean Levy so what does all this mean
well Deadpool 2 already gives us a
fairly straightforward explanation for
how it could work because in the movie's
post credit sequence Deadpool uses
Cable's time travel watch to go back in
time to try to fix everything but it's a
changing the timeline in some big ways
including killing his X-Men Origin self
hey it's me don't scratch just cleaning
up the timelines look eventually you're
gonna hang up the claws and it's gonna
make a lot of people very sad huh one
day your old pal Wade's gonna ask you to
get back in the saddle again and when he
does say yes oh right now obviously I
wear a lot of shirts if you don't
believe me go watch our past videos it's
just me and shirt after me and sure so
trust me when I've got a hot take on
shirts it's backed up by a ton of
personal experience so here's today's
hot take Cuts clothing makes awesome
shirts this is actually one of them I've
got here a black crew neck tee with a
curved hem but you know what cuts
clothing has a ton of options that will
let you find the perfect shirt for you
like check this out oh this is one of
the cuts clothing polos in port color
and it's like so comfy on me I feel like
James Bond you know when he's not
wearing the tux and he's just kind of
like lounging with a shirt I got a
license to Lounge all of cuts clothings
tees are made from Pika fabric which is
super soft and it doesn't pill so you
won't get those weird little you know
fabric balls just from washing your
clothes also these clothes just look
Great Cuts clothing doesn't do the whole
flashy logo thing it's just a simple X
on the scene to let you know that your
shirt's up to Snuff and nothing more
here I'll show you what I mean here you
see that x x marks the spot we're on the
T there's that X it's subtle it's not
forcing itself in your face and if
you're the type who likes all of your
clothes to be comfy Cuts clothing has a
ton of options for you from hoodies to
pants to joggers and jackets Olive Cut's
clothing's products are made with the
same attention to comfort and fit and
their minimalist style makes them the
perfect addition to your wardrobe
whether you're gearing up or going back
to school back to work or you just want
high quality clothes that look good
wherever you go get 15 off today by
going to Cuts dot team slash rockstars
and entering the promo code rockstars
again that's Cuts dot team rockstars and
promo code rockstars for 15 off so when
Ryan Reynolds in this video says that
Logan is set in 2029 and that they're
not touching Logan's death by x24 it
proves that they have thought this
through and don't intend on altering
that that is still the absolute point
the end point for the character and the
MCU will probably reboot Wolverine with
a new variant Seahawk even implied a man
with metal claws already exists in the
616 universe but Deadpool 2 with Cable's
time travel watch already opened up the
Multiverse for these two characters
Jackman could play himself from any
point in the X-Men timeline that CNN
X-Men Origins was set in 1981 but that
portion of the timeline was supposedly
erased by the events of X-Men Days of
Future Past where Logan at time travels
via Consciousness displacement to his
younger body in the year 1973. in the
events of that movie reset the timeline
so that in the present day which we
assume is the year 2023 based on Charles
hoverchair Logan is now back alive with
Charles and cyclops and Jean Gray and
the other X-Men in the X-Mansion and in
recent months I have been speculating
that could be the same universe as
Universe 838 in Multiverse of Madness
because 838 Charles calls back a line
that he said to his younger self in Days
of Future Past just because someone
stumbles and loses their way doesn't
mean they're lost forever just because
someone stumbles loses their way it
doesn't mean I lost forever I don't know
how much Reynolds and Levy will care
about precise Universe designations and
precise years Deadpool 2 also featured a
cameo from the X-Men apocalypse era of
the X-Men when naturally the age those
characters were in the 1980s Deadpool
has always seemed to occupy a side
Meadow reality of a satiric nature but
the fact that Reynolds mentions the year
2029 in particular is telling because
that year came specifically from a 2017
James mangled interview with
comicbook.com that he really threw out
there is just far enough beyond the
epilogue of Days of Future Past and
considered five years to be enough time
so 2029 is really a deep cut known by
the Nerds foolish enough to still try to
unpack the convoluted X-Men timeline so
for Reynolds to mention it proves that
he is one of us nerds and this Deadpool
3 movie will likely address that
timeline Madness maybe even lean into it
because there is a lot of [ __ ] that they
need to make fun of there actually back
in January 2021 Reynolds said that the
original plan for Deadpool 3 was a road
trip between Deadpool and Logan rashamon
style now rashimon was the classic Akira
Kurosawa film that established the
Cinematic concept of an unreliable
narrator where we see the same event
repeatedly Through The Eyes of different
vocal character the details of that
flashback changing each time to reflect
the bias of that character so this road
trip with Deadpool and Logan can now
totally happen in the Multiverse
Deadpool still time displace from the
Deadpool 2 post credit sequence joins up
with Logan shortly after the day's
Future Past ending he teams up with this
Logan because this Logan is a specific
constant with memories stored in his
head of different timelines remember
Logan's healing mutation was the reason
Kitty Pride could project his mind back
in time in the comics is also what makes
Wolverine uniquely sober to the Scarlet
Witch is resetting a reality in the
house of imminent he's the only one
initially who remembers that something's
wrong so this unique quality is why
Deadpool has singled out Logan and needs
this reality scarred mind of his to help
him navigate the Multiverse to find his
way home except that home is going to
end up being in the 616 Universe I mean
think about it these two are really the
perfect Duo to go on this kind of
multiversal road trip using Cable's time
watch to bounce from historical point to
historical point across different
timelines across different universes
from the 838 Universe during its
Infinity War conflict to the 616
Infinity War to the history of the 1940s
with Captain America which we know
Wolverine was a part of to really
anything that happened in the fox X-Men
timeline and then comment on all of it
like how weird it is that Thanos looks
like the guy who supplied Deadpool with
this time travel Tech and then connect
all these universes replaying these
events rashimon style through a new
comedic perspective and I think this is
a perfect opportunity to finally put
Hugh Jackman in a comic accurate
Wolverine costume like the costume and
prop that James Bengal shared Hugh
Jackman unfortunately never had a comic
accurate suitable Wolverine because
Brian's singer banned comic books from
the set of those films but Hugh Jackman
in 2018 revealed an interview with Josh
Horowitz that he would sneak over to
Kevin feige's Office to read comic books
so for Kevin feige Jackman as Wolverine
in the MCU in the comic accurate suit is
a true homecoming a homecoming just in
time to bring him back one true final
time in Avengers Secret Wars let me know
your thoughts on all this and follow me
on Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow me rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]